you know thinking about sort of chat GPT
and its use and so on the one of the big
things about it I think is it's a
linguistic user interface that is so a
typical use case might be and then take
the journalist case for example it's
like let's say I have five facts that
I'm trying to turn into an article or
I'm trying to I'm trying to write a
report where I have basically five facts
that I'm trying to include in this
report but then I feed those five facts
to chat gbt it Puffs them out into this
big report
and then and then that's a good
interface for uh you know another if I
just gave
if I just had in my terms those five
bullet points and I gave them to some
other person the person would say I
don't know what you're talking about
because these are you know this is your
version of this sort of quick notes
about these five bullet points but if
you puff it out into this thing which is
kind of connects to the collective
understanding of language then somebody
else can look at it and say okay I
understand what you're talking about now
you can also have a situation where that
thing that was puffed out is fed to
another large language model you know
it's kind of like you know you're
applying for the permit to you know uh I
don't know grow fish in some place or
something like this and it uh you know
it it um
um and and you have these facts that
you're putting in you know I'm going to
have a you know I'm gonna you know have
this kind of water and I don't know what
it is
um you've just got a few bullet points
it Puffs it out into this big
application you fill it out then at the
other end the you know the Fisheries
Bureau has another large language model
that just crushes it down because the
Fisheries Bureau cares about these three
points and it knows what it cares about
and it then so it's really the the
natural language produced by the larger
language model is sort of a transport
layer that you know is really llm
communicates with llm I mean it's kind
of like the you know I write a piece of
email using my llm and you know puff it
out from the things I want to say your
llm turns it into and the conclusion is
X now the issue is you know that the
thing is going to make this thing that
is sort of semantically plausible
and it might not actually be what you
you know it might not be kind of relate
to the world and the way that you think
it should relate to the world now I've
seen this you know I've been doing okay
I'll give you a couple of examples
um I was doing this thing when we
announced this this uh plugin for for
chat GPT I had this lovely example of a
math word problem some complicated thing
and it did a spectacular job of taking
apart this elaborate thing about you
know this person has twice as many
chickens as this et cetera et cetera et
cetera and it turned it into a bunch of
equations it fed them to wolfen language
we solved the equations everybody did
great we gave back the results and I
thought okay I'm going to put this in
this blog post I'm writing okay I
thought I'd better just check and turns
out it got everything all the hard stuff
it got right in the very end last two
lines it just completely goofed it up
and gave the wrong answer and I would
not have noticed this same thing
happened to me two days ago okay so I I
thought you know I made this with this
chat gbt plug-in kit I made a thing that
would emit a sound would play a tune on
my local computer right so Chachi BT
would produce you know a series of notes
and it would play this tune on my
computer very cool okay so I thought I'm
gonna ask it play the tune that Hal
sang when Hal was being disconnected in
2001 okay so it it there it is Daisy was
it Daisy yes Daisy yeah right so it's
okay so I think you know and so it
produces a bunch of notes and I'm like
this is spectacular this is amazing and
then I thought I was just going to put
it in and then I thought I'd better
actually play this
and so I did and it was Mary had a
little lamb oh wow
oh wow but it was Mary had a little lamb
yeah yes wow so it's correct but wrong
yes it was uh it could easily be
mistaken yes right and in fact I I kind
of gave the I had this quote from Hal to
explain you know it's it's as a the hell
you know states in the movie you know
it's uh the HAL 9000 is you know the
thing was just a rhetorical device
because I'm realizing oh my gosh you
know this Chachi BT you know could have
easily fooled me I mean it did this it
did all the it did this amazing thing of
knowing this thing about the movie and
being able to turn that into the the
notes of the song except it's the wrong
song yeah and uh you know how in in the
movie Hal says you know I think it's
something like you know no Hal nine No 9
000 series computer has ever been found
to make an error we are for all
practical purposes perfect and um
incapable of error and I thought that
was kind of a Charming sort of uh quote
from uh from Hal to make in connection
with uh with what chat GPT yeah in that
case the interesting things about the L
alums like you said that they are very
willing to admit their error
well yes I mean that's a question of the
RH uh the reinforcement learning human
feedback thing oh right that that that's
you know
um the the really remarkable thing about
chat GPT is you know I had been
following what was happening with large
language models and I'd play with them a
whole bunch and they were kind of like
yeah you know it's kind of like what you
would expect based on sort of sort of
statistical continuation of language
it's interesting but it's not breakout
exciting and then I think the kind of
the the kind of reinforcement the the
human feedback reinforcement learning uh
you know in in making Chachi BT try and
do the things that humans really wanted
to do that broke through that kind of
reached the threshold where the thing
really is interesting to us humans and
by the way it's interesting to see how
you know you change the temperature
something like that the thing goes
Bonkers and it no longer is interesting
to humans it's producing garbage yeah um
and it's it's kind of right it's somehow
it managed to get this this Above This
threshold but it really is well aligned
to what we humans are interested in and
uh and kind of that that's um and I
think you know nobody saw that coming I
think uh certainly nobody I've talked to
and nobody who is involved in in that
project seems to have known that was
coming it's just one of these things
that is a sort of remarkable threshold I
mean you know when we built wolf from
alpha for example I didn't know it was
going to work you know we tried to build
something that would have enough
knowledge of the world that it could
answer a reasonable set of questions
that we could do good enough natural
language understanding the typical
things you type in would work we didn't
know where that threshold was I mean I
was not sure that it was the right
decade to try and build this even the
right you know 50 years to try and build
it you know and I think that was it's
the same type of thing with chat gbt
that I don't think anybody could have
predicted said that you know 2022 would
be the year that this this became
possible I think uh you tell a story
about Marvin Minsky and showing it to
him and saying that like no no this time
it actually works yes yes you know it's
the same thing for me looking at these
large language models it's like when
when people were first saying the first
few weeks of chat gbt it's like oh yeah
you know I've seen these large language
models
um and then uh you know and then I
actually try it and uh you know oh my
gosh it actually works and I think uh
it's uh but it but you know the things
and the thing I found you know I
remember one of the first things I tried
was a write a persuasive essay that a
wolf is the bluest kind of animal okay
so it writes this thing and it starts
talking about these uh wolves that live
on the Tibetan plateau and they are
named some Latin name and so on and I'm
like really I'm starting to look it up
on the web and it's like well it's
actually complete nonsense but it's
extremely plausible I mean it's
plausible enough that I was going and
looking up on the web and wondering if
there was a wolf that was blue you know
I mentioned this on some live streams
I've done and so people have been
sending me these pictures
maybe I was onto something